basic motor functions are difficult to
master with a prosthetic hand
but Oksana says she's not ready to give
up
she's already learned to skip using both
her arms
this prosthetic hand is better than the
last one she had because it reads every
impulse of her muscles instead of her
having to strain her arm
because of the war in Ukraine Russian
athletes face many restrictions Roxana
has Big Dreams
I want to get to the Paralympics become
a medalist and then Coach the Russian
national team
this lab still provides Prosthetics to
International markets but sanctions mean
most of its clients are in the Middle
East or Asia
the war and ensuing challenges have
caused supply chain issues but the
company has continued to grow
we have now developed a control which
allows reading potentials from the
remaining tissues and with the help of
AI to learn and control the prosthetic
by moving tissues and reading the
optical senses in the area where the
tissues move
with the conflict in last year's
military draft have created another
problem
tens of thousands of professionals have
left Russia since the war but many state
as well for young entrepreneurs who are
still here the crisis also presents an
opportunity
researchers at a local University are
employing artificial intelligence or AI
to help diagnose colorectal cancer one
of the most common tumors in Russia
they've been able to get new funding
because of the Russian government's
renewed interest in being import
independent
there are more than 40 000 people in
Russia per pathologist the aim of our
project is to automate this process in
order to reduce the workload of
Specialists to reduce the risk of human
error and to enable young Specialists to
gain necessary practical experience
while not risking patient diagnosis
their aim is to enter the global digital
pathology Market estimated to be worth
more than 1.3 billion dollars by 2026.
discounting cancerous biopsies
Pathologists are marking the malignant
issues to predict metastasis
the AI is learning the process and with
time and enough samples it might be able
to simulate the process
and the materials required are either
being locally produced or being imported
from countries like India and China
in the last year we had more funding for
our research projects also we are now
thinking about why we need to buy from
outside when we can do it ourselves and
that's really great it absolutely
transforms the thinking of the
researcher and the project manager
for many Russians like Oksana the
technological advances in research have
proven life-changing and those working
in the medical field and elsewhere hope
they'll persevere despite the challenges
they face
Moscow